Today, I'm going to talk about
testing with an expert, Keith
of Keith's Speaking Academy.
We're going to talk about IELTS,
TOEFL, TOEIC, how these different
tests differ and how they are
important and how we prepare for them.
So without further ado,
let's hear from Keith.
So today, you know, the subject
I want to get into is testing
because testing is such a big part
of, especially English learning.
Nowadays, all languages, they have
their test ... whether it be Chinese,
Korean, they all have their standard
test, you see, and, but in the
case of English, there are a number
of sort of authoritative tests.
So my first question is, what are
the main recognized and unrecognized?
Tests of English, whether it be for
academic purposes, for employment
purposes, for immigration purposes,
what are the main tests and, and,
uh, what is their sort of respective,
you know, role or importance?
If we're talking about tests, you're
mentioning they're like, I think,
proficiency tests, which are tests to
gauge the level of a person in language,
how well they can use the language.
So the big tests, I mean, IELTS
is one of the biggest tests.
It's, it's by Cambridge, it's by a
tri-partner, there's Cambridge, there's
IDP, and there's British Council, but
it's created by Cambridge assessment.
So IELTS is, is one of the larger...
and what does IELTS stand for?
It stands for the International
English Language Testing System.
Okay.
So it's a test...
so if I hear someone say the
Cambridge test, he's actually,
or she is talking about
IELTS.
IELTS is one of the Cambridge tests.
So Cambridge have a suite of tests, um,
which include, um, IELTS, but it also
includes their tests for young learners,
kind of movers, starters, and flyers.
They have tests for school children,
moving up the level, going up to
KET, PET, um, and they've got what
first, I think they now call it
B2 first, advanced proficiency.
So they have different, I guess they'd
be more achievement tests that they're
actually measuring your ability at
a particular level, and they're all
correlated to the CEFR, which is the
Common European Framework of Reference,
which you're probably familiar with.
And so that.
Yeah, so Cambridge are probably one of
the biggest organizations that do that.
You know, that said, I mean,
you've also got Pearson.
They're another testing organization,
the Pearson Test of English.
And there are other organizations that
do testing at school level, at A levels,
and baccalaureate level, internationally.
So there's a whole bunch
of them, actually, a lot.
Okay, now if we're talking about
adults, I know that certainly my
Asian experience has been that
TOEIC and TOEFL seem to be...
Particularly important.
Like more people take those tests.
That's why I say I don't know
who takes the IELTS and who
takes TOEIC and who takes TOEFL.
Can you compare those three?
Sure.
I mean, TOEIC tends to be more
of a business kind of test.
So people who are going into
a business place, possibly the
workplace, would take TOEIC.
TOEFL is similar to IELTS, but
IELTS claims to be, and probably
is a more communicative test.
TOEFL is more traditionally more
popular for going to America.
So if you're migrating or studying in
America, um, TOEFL would be the one if
you're going to North America, that,
that would be the, the, the test to take.
Um, so a lot of countries in Asia
have traditionally taken TOEFL.
However, in the last 10, 20 years iELTS,
which many people associate with Britain,
has been going to British universities.
Actually, IELTS is recognized by
hundreds of thousands of American
universities, North American
universities, as well as around the world.
So nowadays, that difference between
should I do TOEFL or IELTS is a common
question a student in China may have,
because actually they could do either.
Um, they just need to make sure that
it is recognized by the particular
institute that they want to go to.
If we put TOEIC aside as being more of
a, you know, employment related test,
but the actual substance of the tests...
they are  similar, except that IELTS
has a face to face spoken module.
So both tests will test all
of the four skills, reading,
writing, listening, and speaking.
At the moment, I'm not sure exactly
what the speaking test is with TOEFL.
If my memory serves me rightly, it used
to be like a recording, where you would
record your voice, and then somebody
would assess that but the IELTS test,
because they put such huge importance
on it being a communicative test,
having that face to face interaction
with an examiner, where they ask you
questions and you answer, that's one
of the key differences for IELTS.
That is the ultimate test, isn't it?
I mean, I know a lot of people can train
on certain tests and get quite good at
answering multiple choice questions, but
when you're face to face in an interview,
that is the ultimate test, I think.
I think it is.
I think that's why it's
so widely recognized.
And I think that's why employees,
international professional bodies like
the ACCA for accountants recognize it,
like immigration boarders recognize it,
and universities, of course, because
there's a higher level of, not security,
but knowing that what the student
is saying they can do, they probably
can because they've got that score.
But it must make it more expensive
because now you have to have examiners
that are devoting that much time
to interviewing each test taker.
It probably does.
I don't know the price comparison,
but certainly, yes, it's a higher
cost if you've got that face
to face examiner doing that.
So, yeah, and it makes it
logistically a lot more complicated.
I mean, one of the keys to many
tests is keep it simple, right?
There's a balance between getting
the information you need, but
keeping it simple so that you
don't overload the student.
And from the administration side, you want
a test that's fairly easy to administer.
IELTS kind of kicks that
aside and says, we, we want.
The good quality communicative tests,
we're willing to invest in teachers,
examiners, having a face to face test.
Um, although there is now in some
countries, there's an online element ever
since we had the pandemic, the, the idea
of having a face to face interview like
you and me now, it can be done on online.
Right, right.
But it's still the examiner's time.
It's exactly, exactly, that's the thing.
So, in terms of preparing for these tests,
are there good ways to prepare, and is
it different depending on whether you're
preparing for IELTS, TOEIC, or TOEFL?
It's a great question, because
the classic way you prepare for a
test, like when you were at school,
you had the end of term test.
You know the content
that's going to be tested.
And so you would prepare
that content, right?
But for the proficiency test, like
IELTS, you actually don't know the
content because it's not measuring
if you've learnt a specific course.
It's wide, it's wide open.
So the preparation has to be different.
I guess you have to be clear
about the score you need.
So for some people, a
band 5 will be enough.
For other people, a band 7 will
be necessary, so they'll have to
invest more time in preparing.
I mean, my strong belief, and I, and
I say this because I'm familiar with
how the test is constructed and made,
is that the best way to prepare is
to develop your communicative skills.
So your ability to speak and communicate,
your ability to write in English.
Your ability to read and to listen.
So I encourage students actually to
spend 80 percent of their time developing
those skills like they would anyway.
And then 20 percent is
around exam technique.
So you do need to be familiar
with the question type, the exam
technique that you're going to need.
Timing, it catches many people out.
Oh, I didn't know I only had half an hour.
You need to know how it works, question
types, and techniques to make sure you
get the score that you're trying to get.
So people can find examples of
previous tests for these tests?
Yes, for TOEFL, for IELTS, TOEIC,
there are previous tests, what they
call practice tests, on most of those
websites, IELTS website, TOEFL website,
and they'll have practice tests that
students can go in, they can see
the format, they can practice them.
A lot of these organisations now
have free videos, courses, even mini
courses to guide you through and say,
listen, this is the question type.
This is how you should be answering.
What they don't reveal, ever, is the
actual question you're going to be asked.
Right.
That's like letting
the cat out of the bag.
Right.
But the question could be,
uh, on any subject matter.
It could be on, uh, global warming.
It could be on, uh, I don't know
about nuclear, nuclear physics,
but like it could be on anything.
And so what I hear you saying is
that essentially people need to spend
the bulk of their time um, Basically
upgrading their overall language skills,
vocabulary, listening, comprehension,
reading comprehension, reading speed,
ability to speak, ability to write,
accuracy of usage, all of these things.
And then just spend maybe that remaining
15, 20 percent of their time trying to,
you know, ace the system, so to speak.
Ace the system.
Yes, so to speak.
Exactly.
Yeah, learning the technique they
need to get the score that they need.
Absolutely.
That's the way to do it.
And I think it's a challenge because
as you said, there are so many topics.
So a lot of students will ask me,
well, what topics do I prepare?
I mean, there's hundreds.
It could be anything.
And again, I encourage
them to think about it.
If you're developing your speaking
skills, whatever you study,
You'll improve your fluency, your
grammar, and your pronunciation.
So actually, all you're
left with is vocabulary.
That's where the different
topics comes into play.
So you pick and choose your topics.
You don't need to know
them in depth, right?
If you're talking about nuclear
power, you don't need to be an expert.
You don't need to know
that level of depth.
Just the kind of...
thing that you might hear on the news.
So, you know, watching your news
programs, the topics that come up there
can be useful, and they'll give you that
basic vocabulary you need to be able
to talk about it, at least in a test.
Now, I remember in Japan, if I go
and browse the language section of
a bookstore, there are All kinds
of books with TOEFL vocabulary,
IELTS vocabulary, and these books
are full of nothing but words.
How effective are those as a way
of preparing for these exams?
Oh, very, very ineffective and
misleading, I think, really, to be
honest, because they're encouraging
people to think in numbers, right?
So, I need 3000 words.
Oh, look, here's a PDF with 3000 words.
I'll just learn them.
And then, of course, they can't because
they've not learned the context.
They haven't got the input
that you talk a lot about.
They're not getting the context.
They're not really understanding
how they can use the word.
So it never becomes active.
I think it gives the
element of familiarity.
So going back to a lot of people at school
have learned school lists, lists of words.
So there's an element of, I
know what to do with this.
Whereas if you put texts in front of
them, they're not as sure quite what
to do with them for many students.
So they need extra support.
So, I don't know, as a minimum,
as a reference, maybe, maybe,
but to learn vocabulary, no,
probably not.
It's interesting in my sort of
research on how the brain learns,
it turns out that, uh, familiarity
with lots of contexts, sort of a top
down approach to learning, it becomes
at a certain point, particularly
with low frequency vocabulary, more
important than frequency of exposure.
Now, you would think that being
exposed frequently to sort of
individual vocabulary items would
be the most important thing, but
apparently no, because we need
this association with other things.
That's how the brain retains things.
It's got to associate it
with some other things.
So yeah, that's interesting.
I always looked at these
books, 5000 words for TOEFL.
How are you going to learn those?
You think you're learning,
but you're not learning.
So I think we'll close on that.
So basically these tests are important.
We know they're important for academic
uh, you know, getting into university,
immigration, workforce, and basically
you need to upgrade your overall
language skills through practicing
all of the four language skills.
And then there are people who are
very knowledgeable, like yourself,
about the specifics of the test
and the things that the test taker
needs to know about the test in
order to do that little bit better.